there are also minimum scale and maximum
scale properties to which is a way to
limit the extents that the system is
allowed to scale the page on the device
this seems a little esoteric at first
but there is one use that I wanted to
mention I don't want you to think that
I'm biased so after describing how you
need to add initial scale for iOS to
work as expected I wanted to give equal
time for Android if your page width
device-width happens to forcibly
overflow the page like this page where
I've added an element that's very wide
Android will actually do some rescaling
when you change screen orientation to
try to get the whole page to fit onto
the screen now unfortunately it gets it
wrong and it tries to zoom it the wrong
way now the only way that I found to get
around this other than not overflowing
the screen to begin with is to set the
minimum scale and maximum scale
properties to one which will prevent the
user from zooming altogether as well as
disabling automatic scaling let's do
that in the dev tools now now let's try
rotating again we're back to normal here
and now you see that even in landscape
mode we get the proper width now the
problem with this of course is I can't
zoom anymore you really don't want to
disable zooming for your users this is
an accessibility problem so don't do
this in production pages but it can help
your testing in general just don't
overflow the page and you'll be good